[Musique]
le maintien de l'ordre une doctrine qui
est à la fois saluée dans le monde on
entend souvent parler d'excellence
française allait aussi critiqué ces
dernières années quand on observe le
maintien de l'ordre en france au cours
du 20e siècle et début du 21e il ya
extrêmement peu de victimes même si mort
au maintien de l'ordre et une
catastrophe est tout à fait déplorable
on a vu des personnes gravement blessées
on a entendu aussi le terme violences
policières ce débat sur les violences
policières ce qu'il a toujours existé où
il a toujours existé pour la première
grande manifestation parisienne du 6
février 34 on a même pu craindre la
disparition de la toute jeune garde
républicaine mobile dans la presse
s'était déchaînée sur ce qui était
réellement le noyau dur du dispositif de
maintien d'ordre à l'époque
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à porter une entrant pour
décrypter les grands titres de
l'actualité de la journée au sommaire de
ce mercredi 8 décembre j'avais donné
bénir poutine campent sur leurs
positions lendemain de leur entretien
commun de près de deux heures le
président affirme avoir mené c'est son
homologue russe de sanctions comme il
n'en a jamais vu en cas d' attaque
contre l'ukraine mais précise-t-il
envoie des troupes américaines n'est pas
à l'ordre du jour le président russe lui
a jugé la russie avait le droit de se
protéger protéger sa sécurité
il parle néanmoins de dialogue
constructif à l'instar du président
ukrainien nm ce qui qui salue lui aussi
des discussions positives
décryptage en quelques instants avec nos
invités
lafarge angela merkel se tourne
définitivement en allemagne olaf scholz
a prêté serment le social-démocrate
officiellement élu chancelier ce matin
par les députés une élection salué par
emmanuel macron qui lui promet d'écrire
la suite ensemble olaf scholz fera son
premier voyage à l'étranger à paris ce
sera vendredi
emmanuel macron sur les routes de france
à quatre mois de la présidentielle une
immersion dans le quotidien des français
dans une ville hautement symbolique et
politique aujourd'hui vichy le président
pas encore candidat qui a mis en garde
contre toute manipulation l'histoire une
allusion à peine voilée aux polémiques
lancées notamment par eric zemmour et
ses propos sur le rôle du régime de
vichy pendant la seconde guerre mondiale
et justement emmanuel macron qui sera au
coeur de notre rubrique en pensent les
français ce soir nous sommes aidés à la
rencontre de ces fonds ce qui sont en
rupture avec la politique du
gouvernement
ils attendaient des mesures fortes sur
le plan sociétal et environnemental mais
sont déçus à 21h nous entendrons le
témoignage d'un décrocheurs jugé pour
avoir retiré un portrait du chef de
l'état en guise de rêver
[Musique]
les dix meilleures poutines et joe biden
se sont donc exprimés tous deux au
lendemain de leur entretien de près de
deux heures on ira dans quelques
instants rejoindre à moscou notre
correspondante mais glisse d'estrées
pour voir ce qu'a dit le président russe
mais avant cela on prend le chemin de
washington pour retrouver notre
correspondant tome abonnés puisque joe
biden lui aussi est revenu donc sur cet
entretien thomas il ya eu évidemment de
la cordialité de façade hier mais
aujourd'hui le président américain parle
de sanctions aux conséquences
économiques comme la russie n'en a
jamais vu thomas
oui semble-t-il la maison blanche veut
afficher un message de fermeté c'est
déjà ce qu'on avait pu lire dans le
communiqué publié par les services de
communication de la maison blanche
quelques minutes après la fin de cet
entretien entre joe biden et vladimir
poutine c'est aussi ce qu'on avait pu
comprendre lors de la conférence de
presse organisée hier à la maison
blanche et c'est donc aussi ce qu'on a
pu découvrir dans les mots de joe biden
qui est interrogé par les journalistes
américains qui se posent cette question
quelles sont les mesures potentiel que
pourrait prendre washington contre
moscou alors joe biden n'a pas détaillé
réellement ces mesures mais il a répondu
avec une forme d'avertissement écoutez
je n'ai pas mâcher mes mots j'ai été
poli mais j'ai été très clair
si l'envahît l'ukraine il y aura de
graves conséquences de graves
conséquences
des conséquences économiques comme il
n'en a jamais vu comme jamais cela n'a
été fait en matière de sanctions
joe biden qui a également précisé que
l'envoi de troupes américaines pour
défendre l'ukraine n'était pas envisagé
washington avait affirmé hier vouloir
privilégier une désescalade par la voie
diplomatique en fixant ce qui ressemble
à une ligne rouge une invasion
territoriale de l'ukraine par les
troupes russes laurière c'est jake
sullivan le conseiller à la sécurité
nationale de joe biden qui s'était
présentée à la maison blanche pour une
conférence de presse lui non plus n'a
pas réellement en détailler les mesures
que pourrait prendre washington en
revanche il a évoqué le gazoduc north
stream 2 comme un levier possible pour
les pays occidentaux dans leurs
discussions avec moscou écouter
précisément ce qu'il à dire
le fait est que le gaz ne circule pas
actuellement dans le gazoduc nord stream
2 ce qui signifie qu'il n'est pas
opérationnel ce qui signifie qu'il ne
constitue pas levier pour poutine en
effet c'est un moyen de pression pour
l'occident parce que si vladimir poutine
veut que le futur nord stream 2
transporte du gaz il ne prendra
peut-être pas le risque d'envahir
l'ukraine
et puis à l'issue de son entretien avec
vladimir poutine comme convenu joe biden
a débriefé cet échange avec des pays
européens
la france ou encore l'italie il ya
d'ailleurs eu un communiqué qui a été
publié par ces pays un communiqué dans
lequel ils réaffirment leur attachement
à la souveraineté territoriale de
l'ukraine et puis ce mercredi joe biden
à échanger directement avec le président
ukrainien volodimir zelensky qui a dit
que de son point de vue les discussions
entre vladimir poutine et joe biden
avait été positive
merci thomas bonnin en direct de
washington et de son côté le président
russe s'est exprimé lui aussi il dit
d'avoir le droit de protéger la sécurité
de la russie on en parle tout de suite
avec notre correspondante à moscou
maylis d'estrées bonsoir maylis
aujourd'hui vladimir poutine qui
demandent donc des garanties contre
l'expansion de l'otan en direction des
frontières russes
bonsoir stéphanie tout à fait lors d'une
conférence de presse qui s'est tenue
aujourd'hui après des entretiens avec le
premier ministre grec casimir poutine
est revenu sur les sujets évoqués hier
soir avec joe biden le dossier ukrainien
bien sûr est au coeur de les changes
présidentielle et avec lui celui de
l'éventuel élargissement de l'otan qui
préoccupe depuis longtemps la russie
écoutez
cette ago à l'epo canal les
problématiques effectivement nous avons
parlé des problèmes régionaux du conflit
dans le sud est de l'ukraine et on a
également abordé un autre sujet qui est
très sensible pour nous et qui est
associé à cette situation c'est
l'extension de l'otan vers l'est y
compris par l'ukraine c'est l'une des
questions clé de la sécurité de la
russie à moyen terme et même stratégique
nous en parlons constamment nous
avertissons publiquement nos partenaires
que cette inacceptable pour nous
pour bleach une des thèses et elle est
très simple on l'a évoqué aussi hier
bien sûr chaque pays a le droit de
choisir le moyen le plus acceptable pour
lui même d'assurer sa sécurité cela doit
être fait de manière à ne pas léser les
intérêts des autres partis et à ne pas
saper la sécurité des autres pays dans
ce cas de la russie
des geeks
d'après vladimir poutine une possible
admission de l'ukraine à l'otan
s'accompagnerait de l'installation de
contingents militaires de base et
d'armements de l'alliance dans ce pays
ce qui représenterait une menace directe
pour la russie le chef d'état se montre
toutefois optimiste et espère que le
message qu'il a adressé à son homologue
américain ne tombera pas dans l'oreille
d'un sourd écoutez
croyons que nos préoccupations seront au
moins pour une fois entendu même si
jusque là pendant les décennies
précédentes nous évoquions constamment
nos préoccupations en demandant de ne
pas le faire mais les infrastructures de
l'otan n'ont cessé de s'approcher
invariablement de nos frontières
maintenant nous voyons des complexes de
défense antimissile mk 41 en pologne et
en roumanie si nous avons toutes les
raisons de croire que la même chose se
produira au cas où l'ukraine adhérer à
l'otan mais alors sur le territoire
ukrainien
comment peut-on ne pas y penser ce
serait une action criminelle de notre
parti
face à ce qu'elle perçoit comme une
menace persistante la russie souhaite
recevoir des promesses écrites la
garantie sont contre l'expansion de
l'otan par ses frontières occidentales à
cet effet vladimir poutine a annoncé que
moscou l'enverrait la semaine prochaine
aux autorités américaines des
propositions concernant ces garanties de
sécurité la russie compte donc
poursuivre le dialogue avec les états
unis à l'issue de ces négociations
qualifiées d' ouverte et de positive par
le chef du kremlin mais si mélissa des
serait en direct de moscou et vladimir
poutine qu'ils jugent donc à vous l'avez
dit malgré tout constructif sans échange
avec joe biden même son de cloche du
côté du président ukrainien qui salue
des discussions positives alors va-t-on
vers une désescalade sur ce dossier
ukrainien derrière les mots quelles
intentions réelles l'extension de l'otan
vers l'est est elle une menace réelle on
décrypte la situation avec nos invités
[Musique]
et
avec nous pour en parler ce soir en
direct alexandre del valle
géopolitologue docteur en histoire
contemporaine je rappelle que vous êtes
aussi co auteur du livre la
mondialisation dangereuse vers le
déclassement de l'occident aux éditions
l'artilleur bonsoir et merci d'être avec
nous à vos côtés toujours en direct jean
de gliniasty directeur adjoint de l'iris
ancien ambassadeur de france en russie
bonsoir jean de gliniasty merci d'être
avec nous et sur ce plateau max erwan
gastineau politologue spécialiste de
l'europe centrale bonsoir à vous alors
on viens de l'entendre un job identi qui
persiste et signe en il manque les
muscles au lendemain de cet entretien il
menace une nouvelle fois vladimir
poutine de sanctions en cas d'attaqué à
1 comme il n'en aurait jamais vu comment
alexandre del valle interpréter ces mots
assez durs que beaucoup d'observateurs
alors que beaucoup d'observateurs parlé
ce matin de désescalade
en fait non il ya une grande constance
savait depuis les années 90 c'est le
problème qui dure depuis très longtemps
qui n'a jamais été réglé parce que
l'europe est un espace atlantiste et les
états unis n'ont jamais renoncé surtout
depuis 2003 2004 2005 à à recréer une
forme de néo comme times à le voir de
goldbach les stratégies les plus dures
sous la guerre froide et l'accord tacite
qui avaient été trouvées au sortir de
l'union soviétique en union soviétique
c'était c'est collet savaient y avait un
accord tacite de non agression et
l'occident en échange du fait que la
russie avait aboli le pacte de varsovie
l'occident n'allait pas dans les lignes
rouges et mettant des pinsons espace
atlantiste parce que c'est ça le
problème trop vers l'est les pays baltes
savait était la limite acceptable et la
russie pardon l'ukraine c'est la ligne
rouge comme comme comme la géorgie et
malheureusement les américains n'ont pas
donné de signes certes très positif
officielle pour que la l'ukraine rentrer
de longtemps un jour mais il ya une
forte demande en ce sens en ukraine et
les russes ont l'impression que même si
ce n'est pas officiel que les etats-unis
encouragent en sous-main cette atlantide
à sion progressive à venir de ce pays
qui serait vraiment dramatique pour les
relations aussi occident et ce problème
dure depuis 30 ans et malheureusement
l'excellent l'occident n'a pas compris
que ce serait intelligent de trouver un
modus vivendi à un accord me voir même
un statu quo c'est pas forcément un
accord extraordinaire mais on dirait que
l'occident est très sûr de lui-même et
méprise cet espace post soviétique
qui ne méritent même pas le respect d'un
accord certes officieux les années 90
parce que le savez pour les etats-unis
la russie c'est un pays je m'excuse être
vulgaire mais c'est ce que disent les
américains en voie de clochardisation
les américains ne respecte que l'argent
est pour une puissance qui a le budget
de la à peine de l'italie - que la
france ne mérite pas d'être à parité et
bien sûr la russie cherche à paraître à
parité il ya ce mépris fondamental de ce
qu'est la russie et je pense que
malheureusement la tension n'est pas à
la fin ça ne peut que continuer
jean de gliniasty c'est vrai que souvent
les russes ont d'ailleurs on l'a vu avec
toutes les réactions occidentales
aujourd'hui des pays d'europe qui louait
la souveraineté de l'ukraine les russes
qui n'ont pas le beau rôle dans dans
cette affaire pour les occidentaux
alexandre del valle lalala rappelé
l'otan été créée on s'en souvient qui
ont un petit rappel historique
justement au lendemain de la au début de
la guerre froide comme instrument
politique et militaire pour empêcher
l'invasion des pays d'europe par le rsa
c'est ce qu'on n'assiste pas quand même
depuis plusieurs années à une forme de
retour aux sources et on comprend
peut-être aussi l'agacement des des
russes
oui
la question c'est sûr que nous sommes
dans une nouveau type de guerre froide
et que les russes ont mis très
clairement le mille je criais pas de pas
de dents en ukraine jeudi pas de temps
en ukraine parce que en fait les russes
se sont rendus compte que c'est pas
seulement une question d'adhésion de
l'ukraine à l'otan mais que l'otan à de
multiples moyens de coopérer avec
l'ukraine sans une adhésion formelle
donc par exemple un programme qui
s'appelle rennes se portent une notice
qui permet de coopérer sur le plan
militaire de cas sont très intenses de
former des officiers d'envoyer du
matériel
donc on peut peut-être expliquer le
les concentrations de troupes récente
par la volonté russe de faire monter les
enchères et de d'inclure dans la
corbeille qui a été négocié mais on ne
sait pas exactement ce qui s'est dit à
genève 20 ans c'est une vision pardon
donc vu inclure cet aspect là sur le
fond tout le monde est content et très
probablement on va arriver vers une
désescalade les
poutine a dit qu'il était content les
reds qui a dit qu'il était content et
alors que en fait pour lui c'est plutôt
un recul dans la mesure où le les
américains ont dit qu'il n'enverrait pas
de troupes en fait et donc les
américains eux font des moulinets si je
puis dire en disant il peut y avoir des
sanctions très grave mais alors même
qu'ils ont dit qu'il n'interviendrait
pas militairement
directement donc en fait je pense qu'on
va après toute cette gesticulation part
et d'autre on va vers une désescalade
bien autre élément que je voudrais
souligner c'est que
pendant très longtemps les américains
ont laissé en fait aux européens le swan
s'occupait de l'ukraine en première
ligne et là le blocage persistant des
accords de minsk que fait que les
américains ont repris les affaires en
mains si je puis dire et ils ont repris
l'affairé en main avec une idée très
claire c'est que leur priorité c'est la
rivalité avec la chine et que ils n'ont
pas besoin en fait une conflagration et
d'une déflagration en ukraine et donc
c'est un élément supplémentaire qui me
fait penser une désescalade max et wang
est sinon justement vous êtes un
spécialiste de l'europe centrale
l'europe à jean de gliniasty viens d'en
parler c'est vrai qu'elle a été un petit
peu mise à l'écart dans ce dossier avec
poutine et joe biden ont parlé égal à
égal c'est d'ailleurs une forme de
victoire certainement pour la russie
avec une europe qui arrive un petit camp
en second plan oui quand on quand on
parle de la crise ukrainienne on en
parlait de deux acteurs la russie et les
occidentaux je sais pas ce que ça veut
dire les occidentaux en fait ce sont les
américains mais quelle est la position
de l'union européenne dans ce conflit
qu'elle est plus globalement la
politique orientale de l'union
européenne ou au début du mandat de
l'ursuya 21 leyen président de la
commission européenne il était question
d'instituer une commission géopolitique
on en voit toujours pas si vous voulez
la couleur on peut d'ailleurs faire un
parallèle avec le conflit qui a lieu
actuellement entre
la pologne et la biélorussie 1-1 avec un
certain nombre de migrants qui ont été
donc massés à la frontière polonaise
lorsqu'on regarde les réactions et la
manière dont l'union européenne se
saisit de ces sujets on voit une
commission je dirais plus - européenne
connus viennent on va de sanctions en
grand discours sur les valeurs en grands
discours moreau mais on ne voit pas
vraiment de vision stratégique de vision
politique qui permettrait enfin à
l'union européenne
de créer un nouvel espace de discussion
plus apaisée avec la russie puisque en
effet contrairement aux américains ça
n'aura échappé à personne l'europe est
une faune a une frontière commune avec
des états proches de la russie je crois
que nous avons intérêt en effet à
peut-être refonder de nouvelles
relations s'étaient d'ailleurs le sens
de ce que emmanuel macron avait déclaré
dans un grand discours aux ambassadeurs
l'ennemi n'est pas alès l'ennemi est
ailleurs les miettes au sud et bientôt
sienne cette volonté d'apaisement et
l'arrêté russe cette volonté
d'apaisement mais on ne voit pas
concrètement encore aujourd'hui les
fruits de cette volonté de réorienter
l'union européenne de telle sorte
qu'elle s'émancipe d'un giron américain
qui en effet
participe de cette atmosphère de
tensions avec la russie qui se traduit
aujourd'hui concrètement à la frontière
russo ukrainienne elle est sans del
valle emmanuel macron qui va prendre la
tête de la présidente présidence
tournante de l'europe à ce que les
choses peuvent changer c'est vrai que il
a exprimé hier les vélleités
d'apaisement avec vladimir poutine mais
c'est vrai que c'est un il peut toujours
le chaud et le froid
mais il est certain que les pays ont
quand même des traditions nationales
indépendamment des majorités et la
france est quand même avec deux ou trois
autres pays l'union européenne des moins
favorable à une tension et poutine a dit
quelque chose qui n'est pas tout à fait
faux même si ces pro domo quand il a
souligné que ce sont des pays de la
nouvelle europe sous-entendu les
derniers arrivés qui sont des pays de
l'est assez russophobe ou en tout cas
très méfiant vis-à-vis de la russie qui
souvent tous les milieux de la lancia de
l'alliance atlantique et les pays de
l'union européenne à ne pas améliorer
les relations en tout cas là la france
est quand même le pays qui prône le plus
en faveur de cette de ce dialogue parce
que chaque pays a des intérêts et il est
vrai que d'un point de vue polonais même
relativement objectivement sans être
anti russe la russie peut être vu comme
une menace mais pas du tout deux points
de vue français ou même italien est donc
cette extrême division des pays
européens rendus une position commune
assez difficile mais il ya aussi la
guerre du gaz qu'il ne faut pas oublier
aujourd'hui et la rivalité entre le pays
qui voudraient exporter des gaz de
schiste et son rival économique la
russie qui qui avec notamment la
question de nord stream 2 qui
aujourd'hui comme vous le savez est
bloquée pas uniquement dans la volonté
américaine mais aussi par les mesures
anti monopole européenne qui empêche le
une grande entreprise comme gazprom des
gazprom n'est peut-être également
propriétaire des infrastructures et des
pipe line et donc il ya aussi cette
dimension qui est extrêmement importante
et il ya aussi le double jeu de la
turquie qui tantôt se rapproche de l'os
et s est tantôt finalement fourni des
drones extrêmement performant aux
ukrainiens il y a tout un jeune
négociations moi aussi je ne pense pas
qu'il y aura une escalade mais il ya
tout un jeu de négociation là la russie
essaie d'obtenir
un satisfecit en mettant des pressions
mais tout le monde sait qui aura pas de
guerre et emma qu'on peut jouer un rôle
intéressant comme un peu sarkozy à
l'époque de la géorgie en 2008 je pense
que la france a un rôle extrêmement
important de d'éléments apaisant avec
l'allemagne d'ailleurs avant cette
majorité mais les majorités compte aussi
dans les pays puisque aujourd'hui de
cette nouvelle majorité en allemagne est
beaucoup plus hostile à la russie que ne
l'était merkel donc tous ces éléments
sont à prendre en considération
jean de gliniasty évidemment la menace
de sanctions économiques
et surtout ce levier dont on vient de
parler sur north stream 2 c'est ce qui
peut être compliqué pour les russes mais
aussi pour l'europe qui est directement
concernée et finalement
les russes ont tendance à dire que vous
me tenu de toutes les sanctions qui se
sont accumulées depuis six sept ans il
voit pas ce qui pourrait arriver plus
sauf la suppression du système de
compensation swift qui évidemment les
couperet du monde bancaire occidental ça
c'est vraiment l'arme atomique
sans doute les américains on sentait
qu'on te dise qu'il y aura des sanctions
extrêmement grave les russes y prépare
depuis longtemps qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
mis au point un système mir qui pourrait
être comparable et qui s'applique
uniquement aux pays avec lequel la
russie n'y commerce beaucoup c'est à
dire la chine et d'autres pays en tout
cas ceux qui n'appliquent pas les
sanctions mais je pense que la russie
est prêt deuxième
vous parliez de nord stream deuxième
élément nord stream c'est très simple
nord stream 2 fonctionne à quand
l'allemagne et si l'allemagne en a
vraiment besoin donc en ce moment il se
trouve qu'on a plutôt besoin de gaz
russe et donc je pense qu'à un moment ou
un autre north stream fonctionnera donc
à mon sens c'est une menace qui n'est
pas qui n'est pas très crédible mais qui
fait partie de gesticulations nécessaire
mais comme sur le fond je suis persuadé
que malgré les tentations on pourrait
avoir parfois vous ou d'aller régler la
chaire en ukraine par la force il n'y
aura pas il n'y aura pas d' escalade et
que nous avons assisté à une une immense
pièce en fait on a fait monter les
enchères avant on a montré qu'on était
le plus fort chacun de son côté et
maintenant je pense que le soufflé tout
doucement va redescend merci en tout cas
jean louis nesti jour où je vous libère
je crois vous avez des des obligations
ce soir est roi nomme max erwan
gastineau justement sur ce que vient de
nous dire un jean de gliniasty
joe biden qui a précisé que l'envoi des
troupes américaines pour l'heure n'était
pas d'actualité donc ça corpore est ce
que on vient nous dire finalement
beaucoup de gesticulations donc les
muscles mais rien de grave
joe biden qui dit nous avons une
obligation morale et légale envers nos
alliés de l'otan une obligation sacré
qui ne s'étend pas justement à l'ukraine
ça veut dire en gros on gesticule et
effectivement mais pour le moment on ne
va pas aller plus loin que ça oui je ne
crois pas que l'on va aller au delà de
ça comme vous dites je ne contredirai
pas mais mais mes interlocuteurs je
crois que en effet chacun chacun oui
mais en l'occurrence suis en phase avec
ce qui a été dit je crois que chacun
joue sa partition on connaît très bien
en effet les positions de la russie
vis-à-vis de l'otan et des avancées de
l'otan jusqu'à sa frontière je crois que
la question qui se pose aujourd'hui
encore une fois j'y reviens et celle de
l'europe emmanuel macron va demain
annoncé quels seront les grands axes de
la politique française lorsque la france
prendra la présidence de l'union
européenne il est question
de renforcer la souveraineté européenne
notamment l'autonomie stratégique
européenne d'un point de vue français y
compris vis-à-vis des etats-unis or ce
qui est sûr c'est que les tensions qui
existent aujourd'hui un haut niveau au
niveau ukrainien ne vont pas renforcer
la cohésion de la cohésion de l'union
européenne sur ce dossier et je pense
évidemment à la pologne je reviens d'un
déplacement à varsovie il est clair que
pour la pologne le danger russe est
toujours présent cet épisode va leur
arriver et ce qui s'est passé à la
frontière avec la biélorussie et pour
les polonais très clairement une
nouvelle tentative de déstabilisation de
la russie donc le nerf de la guerre se
passe aujourd'hui en pologne si l'on
veut que demain en effet l'union
européenne disons plutôt l'europe est
une velléité propre sur la scène
géopolitique et s'affranchisse de la
tutelle américaine alexandre del valle
le mot de la fin pour vous aujourd'hui
quelle sortie de crise quelle est
l'issue la plus probable selon vous
alors quand on sait que en mai dernier
il y avait cent quarante cinq mille
soldats russes à la frontière de
l'ukraine et aujourd'hui il à 100 milles
et de l'autre côté on a deux cent
cinquante mille soldats l'ukrainien a
armé officieusement très très bien par
les occidentaux mais aussi parlé par les
turcs par les américaines par les turcs
donc on sait qu'aujourd'hui la russie
n'a aucun signe elle ne montre aucun
signe de vouloir déclencher une guerre
conventionnelle donc ça c'est la pure
propagande et et tout le monde le sait
mais chacun a intérêt à faire monter les
enchères pour faire peur et en fait il y
aura une négociation en gros nord stream
2 qui normalement doit bénéficier d'une
exception pour pouvoir être validé
puisque vous savez les lois
antimonopoles l'empêchent de fonctionner
il y avait une exception pour north
stream qui avait été négocié âprement il
va falloir la négocier âprement pour
convaincre la nouvelle majorité
allemandes de débloquer et d'accepter
cette exception pour north stream 2
c'est l'exception aux lois antimonopoles
et je pense qu'on va trouver un accord
les russes ont ont trop intérêt à vendre
du gaz aux européens pour ne pas
peut-être trouvé un accord qui sera
peut-être un accord autour de ce qui se
passe en ukraine orienta ce n'est que
mon humble avis merci en tout cas elle
et précieux en tout cas cet éclairage
merci alexandre del valle merci à max
erwan gastineau et donc à la jean de
gliniasty qui nous a quittés il ya
quelques minutes merci à vous trois
et sur le front à présent de la lutte
anti qu'ovide la question de
l'efficacité des vaccins actuels
inquiète avec l'apparition de mikron on
sait pas grand chose sur ce variant mais
il se répand à grande vitesse à travers
le monde pour le président du conseil
scientifique jean françois delfraissy il
faudrait pas trois mais quatre doses
pour venir à bout de cette nouvelle
souche sud africaine
de son côté l'organisation mondiale de
la santé se veut rassurant sur
l'efficacité des vaccins actuellement
sur le marché ml gogh à
neutraliser omicron grâce à la
vaccination
l'objectif visé par bon nombre de pays
notamment en europe où l'on fait face à
une hausse des contaminations aux copies
de 19 en plus de l'arrivée récente du
nouveau variant pourtant l'organisation
mondiale de la santé se montre plutôt
rassurantes concernant les vaccins
actuels l' oms considère qu'ils sont
efficaces pour les cas liés à omikron en
particulier contre les formes graves
je m'attends très franchement à ce que
les vaccins dont nous disposons
actuellement soit efficace contre les
maladies graves et les hospitalisations
nous devons mesurer cela est confirmé
que c'est le cas nous devons également
confirmé s'il ya une interruption de
cette protection mais je m'attends à
voir une certaine protection et c'est
pour ça que c'est si important la
meilleure arme dont nous disposons
actuellement c'est la vaccination
une efficience tempéré par les groupes
pharmaceutiques pfizer et bio n tech il
estime que la double injection de leurs
sérum mais pas suffisante pour venir à
bout du variant sud africain selon eux
il faut une troisième dose de rappel
pour fournir un niveau suffisant
d'anticorps capable de neutraliser
omicron
pour se protéger contre omicron il faut
entraîner le système immunitaire avec
une vaccination multiples et nous sommes
très heureux de pouvoir affirmer
aujourd'hui que la triple vaccination
avec les vaccins actuels maintien au
niveau de protection robuste et
laboratoires américains et allemands ont
d'ailleurs annoncé travailler sur une
nouvelle version du vaccin
spécifiquement conçus pour neutraliser
omicron une étude menée par un institut
de recherches sud africain vient
également remettre en question
l'efficacité des vaccins actuels les
résultats suggèrent que le variant
omicron résiste aux vaccins fader mais
ne lui échappe pas totalement
au sein de notre institut le laboratoire
du professeur alex cigale a fait cette
étude et a montré qu'il ya clairement
une neutralisation moindre face à
omicron que face aux souches originale
du virus c'est l'arrivée de buran
l'institut nuance malgré tout les
résultats de cette étude estimant qu'il
lui faut traiter avec des données du
monde réel il rappelle qu'en plus de
l'immunité apportées par les vaccins
l'organisme humain a lui aussi les
moyens de se défendre
l épidémie gagne du terrain en
martinique également le couvre-feu est
donc prolongée de deux semaines et tout
positivité et d'incidents sont en haut
sur l'île alors que la vaccination
stagne à peine 40% dé martinique et
possède un schéma vaccinal complet chez
les 12 ans et plus la martinique on
prend une crise sanitaire et sociale
avec des répercussions immédiates sur le
secteur du tourisme à médias ce qui est
difficile à l'heure actuelle d'envisager
la martinique comme destination idéale
pour les prochaines vacances la crise
sociale a sorti à la crise sanitaire et
à l'inquiétude autour du variant omicron
jette un coup de froid sur l'activité
touristique on a peur de ce nouveau
variant parce que en fait vraiment il
ajoute au manque de visibilité pour les
prochaines semaines le marché hexagonal
et quand même notre principal marché et
donc
voilà c'est de cette inquiétude elle
monte pour les professionnels puisqu'en
fait finalement une crise ans en chasse
une autre en fait on depuis 20 mois on
ne gère que des crises les crises la
crise qu vide maintenant la crise
sociale donc c'est vrai que c'est assez
lourd pour les professionnels pour ce
professionnel du tourisme les prévisions
de cette année sont inquiétantes pour la
martinique à peine plus de trois cent
mille visiteurs soit deux cent mille de
moins que l'année dernière alors qu'en
2019 ce chiffre s'élevait à presque 1
million cette restauratrice
martiniquaise a racheté un établissement
janvier 2020 soit deux mois avant le
début de la crise sanitaire elle emploie
aujourd'hui quatre salariés et vit
chaque semaine dans l'incertitude en
novembre son établissement a perdu 40 %
de chiffre d'affaires et 50 % en octobre
c'est vrai que c'est beaucoup de cumul
donc c'est vrai locaux vides depuis mars
2020 et
l'a77 crise sociale depuis à peu près
trois semaines
ça commence à faire beaucoup c'est
difficile matin on se demande si on
pourra arriver au travail si on pourra
ouvrir si on aura de quoi servir le
client en boissons aux repas parce que
les magasins sont vides nos fournisseurs
ne font pas les livraisons puisqu'ils se
retrouvent bloqués sur la route donc
beaucoup de
beaucoup d'imprévus
cette double crise dégrade sans aucun
doute l'image de l'île et le secteur du
tourisme redoutent que les difficultés
s'aggravent en 2022 des perspectives
inquiétantes
d'après jean-yves bonnaire président
d'une association de chefs d'entreprise
le tourisme représenterait 12 % du pib
de la martinique et les antilles où le
scandale du chlordécone revient sur la
table un sujet douloureux qui met en
cause la responsabilité de l'état
pesticide utilisé dans les bananeraies
pendant les années 70 à 90 a en effet
provoqué des pathologies graves chez une
grande partie des guadeloupéens les
procédures judiciaires ouvertes au début
des années 2000 pourrait enfin être
traités les explications de livan sepric
avec sébastien abba
après presque deux décennies de combat
enfin une bataille de gagnée pour les
guadeloupéens un décret reconnaissant le
cancer de la prostate comme maladie
professionnelle suite à l'utilisation du
chlordécone sera adopté d'ici la fin de
l'année mais pour m christophe
leguevaques avocat au barreau de paris
et représentant de l'association
militante vivre en guadeloupe c'est un
décret en demi teinte c'est une avancée
pour des travailleurs des bananeraies
qui ont été extraits l'avait conditionné
s'indigne aller à ce produit n'est pas
de protection par exemple il ne donnait
pas ne respectez pas la dangerosité des
produits et dont ceux qui sont en
première ligne de la contamination ils
sont parmi les plus touchés donc c'est
bien la moindre des choses aujourd'hui
en fait il est presque trente ans après
1990 d'interdiction on accepte de départ
de prendre en charge leurs
problématiques de santé au type de
manifestation ça c'est un bon joueur
mais il faut pas qu il a vocation à
trouver puisque à côté de ça vous avez
90 % de la population qui elle est
contaminée par nous propose la cour
d'école qui n'est pas pris en charge et
pour laquelle l'état ne propose rien
donc c
avancée pour certaines mais c'est
surtout
classé comme cancérogène probable par l'
oms le chlordécone est interdit aux
états unis depuis 1976 en hexagone il
faut attendre 1990 et trois ans de plus
pour les territoires et collectivités
d'outre-mer mais le mal est fait le lien
entre le produit et le cancer de la
prostate est aujourd'hui avéré ici en
guadeloupe on a deux fois plus de
cancers de la prostate que dans
n'importe quel autre endroit de france
et on en meurt deux fois plus par
rapport à tous les autres endroits de
france et donc avec l'inserm j'ai
réalisé une étude qui est terminée
depuis 2010 et qui a mis en évidence que
plus vous avez un taux de chlordécone
important dans votre sens et on en a
tous plus ou moins et plus le risque de
cancer de la prostate s'élève donc ça
veut dire que c'est un facteur de risque
supplémentaire
il y a les ascendance africaine il ya
les gens âgés il ya des antécédents
familiaux mais en plus il ya une partie
de ses 500 nouveaux cas de cancer de la
prostate qui sont attribuables à
l'empoisonnement
l'exposition au chlordécone pour les
guadeloupéens c'est l'heure de la
réparation le comité de défense des
usagers de l'eau en guadeloupe exige une
réhabilitation totale du réseau d'eau
potable de lille aujourd'hui contaminée
par le pesticide
les victimes doivent aussi vivre avec la
maladie en attendant une prise en charge
complète de l'état après avoir reconnu
que l'auteur était empoisonnée j'ai
déposé plainte concernant le chlordécone
au tribunal pénal de la santé à paris
depuis le 3 mars 2002 et depuis le 3
mars 2002 ah ben 6 après j'ai été reçu
par un juge ce qui les ennuie sais que
je dois demander un million cinq d'euros
de dédommagement pour tout voir
européens qui ont été touchés par ce
fameux protocole y compris moi même
d'ailleurs je sors de la prostate en ce
moment parce qu'on touchait avant ces
différents pesticides à mains nues sans
gants sans protection sans rien du tout
ce seront nous faut c'est faire de
travailler dans les bananeraies comme ça
il fallait boire il fallait manger donc
on y allait en 9 thèmes après on a été
plus touchée germain parents et ses
compatriotes guadeloupéens pourrait être
fixé sur la responsabilité de l'état
dans cette affaire dès l'année prochaine
l'état français qui est attendu au banc
des accusés lors d'une audience fixée à
l'été 2022 pour l'heure le chlordécone
demeure un traumatisme collectif qui
nourrit la colère populaire sur tout le
territoire antillais
olaf scholz reprend les rênes de
l'allemagne deux mois et demi après les
législatives de nouveau chancelier fait
revenir le centre gauche sur le devant
de la scène le social-démocrate referme
donc les 16 années de l'ère angela
merkel le patron du parti spd accède au
pouvoir avec une idée dit que coalition
verts libéraux alors qu'elle défile
va-t-il devoir relever éléments de
réponse avec peter oliver correspondant
verte et international à berlin
l'ancien maire de hambourg 63 ans est le
nouveau chancelier de l'allemagne il
prend la suite d'un gala merkel qui a
été 16 ans au pouvoir
la fiole était ministre des finances et
vice chancelier dans le dernier
gouvernement dans gala merkel il mène
une coalition tripartite une coalition
feux tricolores comme on l'appelle en
allemagne pour la première fois au
sommet du gouvernement
qu'on l'appelle coalition feux
tricolores en raison des couleurs des
différents partis qui la constituent
les sociaux-démocrates en rouge et les
verres en verre et les
libéraux-démocrates jaune ou orange pour
ceux qui souhaitent mener la comparaison
jusqu'au bout
mais que veulent t'ils et bien leur
manifeste de 177 pages ou accords de
coalitions s'intitulait oser davantage
de changements et il semble impatient de
faire des avancées notamment dans le
domaine de l'approvisionnement
énergétique allemand et tout
particulièrement pour la sortie du
charbon ils ont avancé cette échéance à
2030 plutôt que 2038 il souhaite
également d'ici là que 80% de l'ailé he
is it et allemandes proviennent de
sources renouvelables mais ce sont des
objectifs à long terme
à court terme le spectre de la pandémie
de coronavirus plane sur le début de
mandat de olaf scholz
c'est d'ailleurs vendredi que son
premier ensemble de mesures qu'ovide
passera devant le bundestag et je suis
impatient de savoir comment cela va être
reçue notamment avec la vaccination
obligatoire pour certaines catégories
professionnelles dans la santé en
particulier qui est olaf schulze l'homme
eh bien il est loin d'être le plus
charismatique des politiques allemands
ce qui n'est pas peu dire au vu des
stéréotypes
on le considère souvent comme un
pragmatiste prosaïque quelqu'un qui a
été constamment sous apprécié mais jugé
mais sous-évalué par certains au cours
de sa carrière politique
oui surtout cas il a pris la tête d'un
parti social démocrate qui il y a un an
était mort et enterré et aujourd'hui il
tient le poste le plus éminent de la
politique allemande seize ans après le
dernier chancelier de ce parti gerhard
schröder
a connu un certain nombre de scandales
pour quelqu'un qui n'est pas considérée
comme très charismatique
il a essuyé en tant que maire de
hambourg des critiques pour la gestion
des émeutes du g20 de 2017 c'est qu'ils
ont fait des dégâts dans les quartiers
nord de cette ville portuaire ce match
top
je peux vous le garantir car j'étais sur
place
en tant que ministre des finances il a
était adjacent un nombre de grands
scandales comme le scandale comme aix et
le scandale wirecard pour lesquels des
enquêtes se sont fait tout autour de lui
mais sans jamais vraiment l'impliquer
août hier sa réputation
faut noter que durant sa campagne pour
la chancellerie les bureaux du ministère
des finances ont fait l'objet de
perquisitions de la police dans le cadre
d' enquête pour corruption et
malversations financières mais si tu
n'es rien de cela n'a impacté sa
candidature il a continué sa campagne et
obtenu le poste
en matière de reconnaissance politique à
l'international le président chinois xi
jinping lui envoyer un message via
l'ambassade publié sur twitter disant
qu'il souhaitait continuer la
coopération avec l'allemagne
la chine était le second plus grand
partenaire commercial de l'allemagne en
2020 lorsque olaf scholz a été confronté
à des questions ce mardi qu' et
requérait en substance qu'il soit
critique envers la chine qu'il s'est
montré un peu fuyant il serait
intéressant de voir comment les
relations entre berlin et pékin se
développe au cours de son mandat à la
chancellerie
concernant les relations avec la france
emmanuel macron le président français
lui a donné rendez vous vendredi pour
une rencontre organisée à paris ce
n'est qu'un au revoir au célèbre couple
franco-allemand guélat merkel emmanuel
un mec remplace maintenant à l'air chaud
qui sera reçu à l'elysée vendredi par le
président français l'occasion pour les
deux hommes de faire connaissance sont
pour autant éviter les sujets qui
fâchent 4 ça pique nique olaf scholz le
successeur dans gala mercal a réussi à
bâtir très rapidement une coalition
aimablement surnommé feux tricolores
avec les sociaux démocrates de son parti
le spd les verts et les libéraux le
nouveau chancelier donne le ton avec un
gouvernement paritaire où les ministres
femmes occuperont des postes d'ordinaire
réservé aux hommes ces intentions
redonner un élan moteur au pays
toutefois écartelée entre l'austérité
budgétaire des libéraux de la coalition
et les investissements verts réclamées
par les écologistes pour accueillir ce
mariage de la carpe et du lapin un super
ministère a été créée couple en économie
et climat tout un symbole alors que la
france a accouché d'une loi au rabais en
matière d'écologie olaf scholz compte
convertir l'industrie aux exigences de
la transition environnementale
mais les libéraux aux finances tiendront
bien serrer les cordons de la bourse
pour débuter cette nouvelle ère olaf
scholz rendra visite locataire de
l'elysée les deux hommes se sont déjà
rencontrés à de multiples reprises
lorsque la fiole c'était maire de
hambourg puis ministre des finances
allemand le couple franco-allemand
incarnée par angela merkel emmanuel
macron s'est toujours montrée stable et
coopérants olaf scholz qui était vice
chancelier social-démocrate de la droite
se situe dans le droit fil de cette
relation le programme de la coalition
évoque le cadre d'un partenariat
franco-allemand fort voilà ce que dit
olaf scholz de cette visite officielle
qu'il est d'usagé d'accorder à la france
second poids lourd européen l'amitié
franco-allemande est essentiel si nous
voulons réaliser des progrès pour lui et
la souveraineté européenne
il se trouve que c'est une bonne
tradition alors que la france s'apprête
à assurer la présidence tournante de
l'union européenne pour six mois parlons
de cette vision commune de ce que
devrait être l'union olaf scholz
souhaite la sortir de l'ornière et de la
paralysie il veut voir advenir un état
fédéral européen et un parlement
européen renforcé tout comme le futur du
monde sera façonnée par de nombreux pays
influents pas seulement 2 n'est fini
c'est pourquoi il est important que dans
le futur l'europe agisse avec force et
souveraineté
il plaide pour un poste de ministre
européen des affaires étrangères et des
listes transnationales
ainsi que pour l'adoption de vote à la
majorité qualifiée et non plus à
l'unanimité pour les questions liées aux
affaires étrangères et ceci afin
d'empêcher les vétos ce coup de pied
dans la fourmilière surpasse les
ambitions contrariées d' emmanuel macron
affirmé en début de mandat plusieurs
bémols toutefois la rigueur budgétaire
desserrer au pire de l'épidémie de covin
fera son retour autres rats les libéraux
ne veulent pas d'une dette européenne
mutualisés ils ont imposé de freiner
l'endettement ils sont frileux quant à
une réforme du pacte de stabilité et de
croissance que le président français
entend porter emmanuel macron et
secondes et dans cette optique par le
chef du gouvernement italien mario
draghi qui pourrait jeter une ombre très
latine sur la lune de miel franco
allemande par ailleurs si le président
français le chancelier convoite la
souveraineté stratégique de l'union
européenne il ne la voit pas la même
aune emmanuel macron souhaite créer une
défense européenne renforcée avec des
moyens militaires tandis que l'allemagne
pacifiste accepte l'idée d'une
coopération accrue entre les armées
nationales d'europe pas davantage ce qui
ferait bien les affaires de l'otan autre
point de friction probable la vision sur
le futur de l'énergie l'allemagne
souhaite sortir du charbon d'ici 2030
développer les énergies renouvelables
tout en délaissant l'atome tandis qu
emmanuel macron vient d'insister sur
l'exploitation de l'énergie nucléaire à
court et moyen terme et soit des
investissements dans des mini réacteurs
les verts allemands vont voir rouge et
olaf scholz risque d'avoir toutes les
peines du monde pour accorder les 50
nuance de son feu tricolore il était
peut-être finalement plus simple de
tenir la main d'angela merkel immobile
donc stable que de s'accorder avec olaf
scholz animé d'une fièvre et formatrice
est pris entre plusieurs feux et pour en
parler nous sommes avec aymeric
montville philosophe rédacteur en chef
de la revue étincelles bonsoir monsieur
menville et merci d'être avec nous on
vient d'entendre avec katia alors macro
compatibles ou parents ça sera plus
compliqué moins compliqué qu'avec un
gala merkel avec les choses se passaient
plutôt bien pour emmanuel macron bas
étant donné que c'est une coalition un
petit peu disparate ça ça reflète très
bien mais en même temps ma chronique
c'est à dire que vous avez un libéral
aux finances ce qu'est macron par
certains côtés
l'autorisation du cannabis macron à
décoter libéral libertaire et puis des
fois l'ordolibéralisme temps un peu dans
la halle côté l'alternance de la carotte
et du bâton avec
l'obligation vaccinale et en même temps
l'atlantisme qui rentrent en force la
nouvelle miss des affaires étrangères
écologique donc pour américaine parce
que c'est en période parti qui est
aujourd'hui qui venait d'extrême gauche
1 0 110 et qui aujourd'hui est un parti
qu'on pourrait qualifier de
néoconservateurs au sens américain du
terme ni aux craintes alors on a parlé
de l'allemagne de ses rapports avec la
russie tout à l'heure en évoquant le
dossier ukrainien avec alexandre delval
et ça ça va peser risque est peut-être
un petit peu de changer le jeu
géopolitique
oui complètement puisque ça fait déjà
plusieurs mois que
anna lena bareback qui donc la nouvelle
le mystère ministre des affaires
étrangères avait affirmé son opposition
à nord stream ii et le fait qu'elle
souhaitait que l'ukraine intègre à
l'otan
il faut savoir qu'à un moment les verts
les grünen militait pour la sortie de
l'allemagne de l'otan et contre les
guerres et aujourd'hui milite pour que
l'ukraine rentrer rentrer dans l'otan et
commencer le l'otan n'est pas la réponse
aux packs d'eau vers celui c'était le
contraire c'est l'otan qui a commencé
normalement à partir de la dissolution
du pacte de varsovie on s'attendait
quand même à ce que donc plus ou moins
dissoudre cette alliance est au
contraire maintenant elle s'étend sur
l'ex territoire de l'urss et c'est avec
l'accord de l'allemagne c'est
catastrophique je crois que il faut
prendre la mesure de ce problème alors
peut-être que vous parliez de
négociations qui vont avoir lieu autour
de north stream 2 oui c'est très
intéressant bien sûr qu'il va y avoir de
négociations et ça augmente
malheureusement les enjeux ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que c'est simple la formule
elle est très claire on prend des
sociaux-démocrates comme olaf scholz
pour faire les mesures les plus anti
social parce que ça en donne une
caution de gauche tout cela et on prend
les partis dits pacifiste pour prendre
les mesures les plus d'ingérence
au nom de respect des minorités le droit
international en 45 c'est la charte de
l'onu et c'est contre l' ingérence dans
la vie des états au nom du principe
d'une minorité on fait de jouer sur les
minorités comme elle l'avait fait
l'allemagne nazie pendant avec les chais
date par exemple c'est pour ça qu'on a
interdit ça et ceux qui ont permis ce
retour de l'allemagne ce retour de la
politique allemande ce sont les verts ce
sont les verts au kosovo ce sont les
verts la gauche qu'à fischer sous sous
gerhard schröder c'était la pire
politique parce que soi-disant de gauche
qui a rien de pire qu'une fausse gauche
vont me encore une vraie droite et qui y
compris pour les questions de la paix ça
va être très très très dangereux là
justement qu'un hors stream 2 c'est un
levier on l'a on l'a expliqué en début
d'émission explique jean expliqué ça a
été effectivement expliqué par den
quelle quelle va être la position du
nouveau chancelier et de cette coalition
par rapport à ce dossier
heureusement ils sont pas seuls à
décider il ya aussi des intérêts y
compris économique en allemagne qui ont
pas tous se terrait à gerhard schröder
lui-même avait des intérêts avec
l'économie russe mais aussi défendre et
c'est une position classique et l os
politique à la ville vibrante il ya
aussi ce courant dans le spd que la
politique classique dans le temps c'est
aussi une politique de raison peut-être
qu'il pourrait peut-être qu'il pourrait
elle a continué mais le problème c'est
qu'effectivement c'est une coalition et
s'attend effectivement vers cette espèce
de fausse gauche qui est en fait une
gauche impérialiste et c'est
effectivement très très dangereux les
rapports de force sont en train de
sauter en train de changer parce
qu'encore madame merkel participé aux
sanctions mais en tant qu ancien membre
elle parlait russe elle a appris le
russe au rdr elle avait une scène qu'on
va lui faire dire n'importe quoi sur la
russie comme à une certaine partie de la
population allemande c'est là où
l'allemagne comme très différence de la
france
il ya une proximité avec la russie les
mots après la guerre qui permettait
qu'on ne dise pas n'importe quoi qu'on
ne pouvait pas dire n'importe quoi
notamment en allemagne au moment de la
guerre de yougoslavie alors qu'en france
on avait toujours le roman c'était
c'était les serbes qui était responsable
de tout ça le faisait gober ça la
population française comme s'il n'y
avait pas de station croatie et pas de
djihadistes ont besoin en eau mais ce
n'était pas possible donc il ya toujours
aussi qu'aujourd'hui ça ça va changer
justement parce qu'on sait que les
rapports entre produits n'ont pas
toujours été au beau fixe l'allemagne et
la russie est ce que ça va empirer
encore davantage malheureusement va
peut-être même la regretter si j'en
crois le ce nouveau cours et puis c'est
aussi une nouvelle génération qui keane
qui n'a pas conscience du poids de la
guerre du de ce que ça signifiait
l'affrontement de l'allemagne et de la
russie
c'est une question importante en europe
c'est la question migratoire en voit
avec les opinions publiques 1 qui se
désintéressent de moins en moins ce
sujet on se souvient l'un des des points
de ce mandat d'un gala merkel de saison
1 ses mandats le choix d'accueillir ces
migrants a notamment 2015 un venu de de
syrie avec ce nouveau couple franco
allemand ça pourrait donner une nouvelle
impulsion sur les questions migratoires
en europe qu'elle va être là aussi les
les changements ou non qu'elle s'attende
où j'ai pas l'info particulière sur la
politique de choc par rapport à ces
questions simplement parce qu'il a
changé par rapport à 2015 c'est que la
crise se situe exactement en biélorussie
mais elle est le poids des sanctions qui
sont prises contre leur bien réussi ou
contre la russie qui oblige et aussi ces
pays à se tourner par exemple pour leurs
vols internationaux vers d'autres pays
qui ont été en plus ravagées par les
pays de l'otan il faut notamment la
pologne qu'il d'une hypocrisie et sans
nom alors que la bio réussi
contrairement à ce qu'on dit travail
avec les organisations humanitaires pour
essayer de régler cette question
évidemment tragique et mais
effectivement c'est ça qui est ça qui
haute ville à vue c'est ça qui est en
course et c'est cette crise migratoire
qui est très différente de celle de 2015
lui que mais elle est aussi le fruit des
des sanctions contre la russie la
biélorussie et la biélorussie merci
beaucoup américaine envie de philosophes
rédacteur en chef de la revue étincelles
d'avoir été avec notre
et avant de recevoir vendredi le nouveau
chancelier allemand emmanuel un mec
qu'on présentera demain les axes de la
présidence française de l'union
européenne à partir du 1er janvier pour
six mois la france succédera à la
slovénie dans le rôle d'animateur des 27
alors quelles priorités se fixe le
président français pour renforcer la
souveraineté européenne éléments de
réponse avec far as milk
renforcer la souveraineté européenne
un des objectifs affichés par emmanuel
macron avant son nouveau mandat européen
succédant à la slovénie la france
prendra les rênes du conseil de l'union
européenne le 1er janvier 2022 lors de
cette présidence de six mois emmanuel
macron compte également s'attaquer à la
question environnementale et renforcer
les liens avec l'afrique des projets
présentés comme essentielle par le
président de la république
nul n'ignore le débat public dans notre
pays en ce moment quand les choses
deviennent difficiles on dit c'est la
faute de l'europe une europe qui pourra
faire ses propres choix militaires
technologique culturel de valeur nous
avons des débats provinciaux là où les
vrais sujets sont de savoir ce que nous
voulons devenir par rapport au modèle
chinois au modèle américain
problème un tel investissement pourrait
faire perdre du terrain au chef de
l'état alors des futures présidentielles
car si le projet peut amener une
visibilité conséquente aux candidats
macron il pourrait également l'éloigner
de ses électeurs
selon certains hauts fonctionnaires à
l'elysée où quelques opposants
politiques le pari est risqué il faut
que le président garde beaucoup
d'énergie pour le national et ses
déplacements en france c'est une
nécessité absolue pour lui car les
français ne le connaissent pas depuis
longtemps c'est une faute assez grave
d'avoir maintenu le calendrier cela pose
un problème démocratique car quelle va
être la légitimité d'un président et
d'un gouvernement à agir au niveau
européen alors qu'ils sont en pleine
phase de renouvellement le conseil de
l'union européenne réunis les 27 pays
membres et permettra à la france de
présider les réunions et les débats tout
en assurant la continuité des travaux
entamés au sein de l'union
ces fonctions supplémentaires s'annonce
chronophage pour emmanuel macron malgré
un européisme affiché aux côtés d'angela
merkel depuis plus de quatre ans le
couple franco allemand n'est pas parvenu
à calmer les critiques des
eurosceptiques au sein même de l'union
européenne
est restée avec nous dans quelques
instants emmanuel macron lancer à la
conquête de l'europe mais aussi sur les
routes de france à quatre mois de la
présidentielle le candidat non-déclaré
se montrer au chevet des territoires
aujourd'hui à vichy yémen mais kron a
mis en garde contre toute manipulation
de l'histoire allusion à peine voilée à
la controverse sur le régime de pétain
lancé par éric un zemmour alors macron
petit de conquérir le coeur des français
c'est notre débat est la question que
l'on vous pose sur rt france
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple c'était
une volonté collectés vous le savez pour
moi que des candides n'y a pas
d'alternative on sent du comité il est
clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez des sous les
libéraux uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï pg les gens ne
s'étaient des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent c'est des gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas une
république parlementaire ça se passe en
direct puisque on est en direct il y a
quand même la liberté je vous remercie
de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
la hausse des prix du gaz l'électricité
touche directement au moins 36 millions
d'européens pour la france plus question
de fermer 14 réacteurs pourraient nuire
à 50% la part du nucléaire en 2035
l'allemagne est dans une toute autre
logique devenu club by gaz russe en
europe elle s'oppose à la stratégie
nucléaire de la france mieux à est en
crise tout cela c'est le reflet en fait
d'un conflit plus large dont elle n'est
que la proie est aujourd'hui la victime
les français ont découvert une réalité
qu'il n'avait pas compris ou plutôt
qu'on ne leur avait pas expliqué
[Musique]
la nouvelle calédonie je fous l'ultime
référendum sur l'indépendance est
maintenue au 12 décembre quel poids
représente aujourd'hui avocat de m les
indépendantistes dans le paysage
politique en nouvelle calédonie il ya
une progression du oui le peuple
originel concernés par la dépendance il
l'indépendance fils d'adam de son nom
représente la france pour la société
calédonienne il n'y a pas eu de n 1
roger d'arte france et c'est à dire
quand même qu'il n'est pas seul à liège
consumérisme d'assistanat ou ce que dit
j'ai un économisme une économie assistée
sous perfusion si on te des statistiques
cruel on peut retrouver plus de kanaks
dans les prisons les hôpitaux
psychiatriques et marche une société que
dans la réussite au niveau social
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose
une convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
le long chemin de la réconciliation
nationale depuis deux décennies en côte
d'ivoire au moins le processus est il
sur le point de se concrétiser le
blocage véritable se situe au niveau des
zones politique plus de 3000 ivoiriens
en perdront la vie lors de la crise post
électorale de 2010 2011 avec beaucoup de
tension ça tire de partout c'était
vraiment l'as cozes et quand on
souhaitait envoyer des tasses des balles
par ci par là envoyer des cadavres en
moins d'une semaine c'était c'était le
chaos après 2010 il y avait deux camps
celui des vainqueurs et des vaincus
est-ce que la situation s'est quand même
amélioré à ce niveau le châtel que la
victime se plaignent toujours le fait
est que sur le terrai les divisions
existent toujours le fait est que le
climat politique n'est pas encore
véritablement apaisé
[Musique]
où
un des freins à priori du nucléaire
c'est l'émergence dé nouvelles sources
d'énergie aujourd'hui nous sommes le
pays qui produit l'électricité la plus
décarbonés au monde on peut rêver à
couvrir toute la planète de d'éoliennes
mais quand ça produit un tiers du temps
que fait-on pour le reste à puis il ya
aussi la démographie ils en sont
toujours à l'afrique quand même avec un
milliard d'habitants plus la surface de
l'afrique ne sera pas suffisante pour
mettre des panneaux solaires ou sinon ça
se fera au détriment de l'agriculture on
joue aux apprentis sorciers y compris au
niveau européen quand un pays comme
l'allemagne décide du jour là ma
d'arrêter le nucléaire trouvera les
centrales à charbon l'allemagne est le
plus gros pollueurs européens
aujourd'hui le giec qui a sonné l'alarmé
sur les risques de réchauffement
climatique dit bien que les besoins en
électricité sont considérables d'ici
2050 il faudra 50 % de production
électrique en plus comment va-t-on faire
[Musique]
il est 21h merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire emmanuel macron sur les routes
de france à quatre mois de la
présidentielle une immersion dans le
quotidien des français dans une ville
hautement symbolique et politique
aujourd'hui vichy le président pas
encore candidat qui a mis en garde
contre toute manipulation de l'histoire
une allusion à peine voilée aux
polémiques lancées par eric zemmour et
ses propos sur le rôle du régime de
vichy pendant la seconde guerre mondiale
et justement le président qui sera au
coeur de notre rubrique qu'en pensent
les français nous sommes allés ce soir à
la rencontre de ces français qui sont en
rupture avec les politiques du
gouvernement
ils attendent des mesures fortes sur le
plan sociétal et environnemental mais
sont déçus nous entendrons le témoignage
d'un décrocheurs jugé pour avoir retiré
un portrait de le chef de l'état en
guise de rébellion
[Musique]
emmanuel macron poursuit donc son tour
de france comme un air de campagne à
quatre mois de la présidentielle
aujourd'hui le président sortant pas
encore candidat s'est rendu à vichy on
en parle avec un autre reporter écrivain
rossi bonsoir guillemin emmanuel macron
qui était donc plongés en immersion
totale au coeur de ces villes françaises
les mains
et oui tout à fait un stéphane il était
déjà allé à la rencontre des français
hier à vierzon et à bourges dans le cher
objectif parler avec les habitants et
les professionnels de leur vie au
quotidien dans ces territoires ruraux
rebelote donc aujourd'hui après avoir
présidé ce matin le conseil des
ministres par visioconférence emmanuel
macron est allé à la rencontre pendant
une demi-heure des habitants de moulins
dans l'allier avant de prendre la route
de vichy pour une visite mémorielle cela
faisait plus de 40 ans que cette ville
n'avait pas accueilli deux présidents
français de la dernière fois c'était
valéry giscard d'estaing en
1978 alors emmanuel macron s'est
recueilli devant la stèle en mémoire aux
6500 juifs déportés victimes de la rafle
du 26 août 1942 il était accompagné des
époques lars feld figure de la défense
de la mémoire des déportés et puis il a
fait un arrêt devant la plaque en
l'honneur des 80 parlementaires qui
avaient refusé de donner les pleins
pouvoirs au maréchal pétain
egima on peut supposer alors qu'à quatre
mois de la présidentielle cette visite
mémorielle michy ne doit rien au hasard
eh bien non c'est fanny bien évidemment
vous avez raison alors il n'est pas
question de dire que vichy ne mérite pas
de visites présidentielles et bien
évidemment mais il s'agit là d'une
stratégie de campagne car ce que je ne
vous ai pas encore dit c'est qu'après
cette visite mémorielle emmanuel macron
a accordé un entretien à france bleu
pays d'auvergne entretien au cours
duquel il a mis en garde contre je cite
et les manipulations de l'histoire une
phrase qui vise directement l'un de ses
adversaires politiques dans cette
campagne présidentielle cet adversaire 7
eric zemmour eric zemmour qui avait
déclaré que le maréchal pétain avait
sauvé des juifs français une déclaration
qui avait provoqué l'indignation de
toute une partie de la classe politique
et qui avait valu au polémiste écrivain
et candidat nationaliste de se voir
qualifier de révisionniste or cela fait
quelques mois maintenant que la majorité
est temps de se placer comme adversaires
de l'extrême droite une façon de
polariser le débat en faveur du camp
macron et quel meilleur endroit que
vichy pour ce faire vichy associé à tout
jamais origines qui porte son nom au
grand dam d'ailleurs du maire de la
ville vichy associé au nom du maréchal
pétain l'un des endroits où l'on peut se
rendre si l'on veut se placer comme
adversaire du nationalisme alors vous le
voyez là stéphanie s'il n'est pas
officiellement déclaré emmanuel macron
est bel et bien un candidat en campagne
a effectivement merci démarre aussi pour
toutes ces précisions emmanuel macron
qui cherchons que on l'aura compris à
créer du lien avec certains français qui
lui reproche parfois d'être hors sol un
président qui a suscité la colère de
certains français notamment des
activistes luttant contre le
réchauffement climatique
ceux que l'on surnomme les décrocheurs
des portraits mais kron du nord au sud
ils ont défrayé la chronique en
décrochant 150 portraits du chef de
l'état il y a deux ans pour dénoncer
l'inaction du président dans notre
rubrique est qu'en pensent les français
nous allons ce soir à la rencontre de
l'un d'entre eux étienne coubard un
reportage signé david khalifa avec fred
search
je suis devant la mairie du 4e
arrondissement pour rencontrer etienne
coubard décrocheurs de portraits et
emmanuel macron et militants à une vie
comme 21 bonjour etienne merci de
répondre à nos questions alors nous
sommes en février 2019 et vous décidez
avec plusieurs militants de la rb
commentaires de décrocher des portraits
des manuels macron comment vous est
venue cette idée racontez nous un peu
cette journée particulière tout d'abord
on va dépenser réveiller assez tôt et on
est du coup s'est déplacé jusqu'à
la mairie ici tout simplement en fait
nous sommes montés jusqu'à là jusqu'à la
salle des mariages où nous avons
simplement décrocher ce portrait puis
nous avons fait une photo à l'intérieur
et à l'extérieur puis moi je suis parti
avec en fait en vélo pour simplement
l'emmener dans tout s'est passé vraiment
très tranquillement on est juste monté
et descendu alors c'était un geste fort
on imagine assez significatif pour vous
pourquoi avoir choisi ce geste justement
c'est un symbole à ses clients
finalement pour elle a élevé qu'au 21ème
pour vous les experts tels que les
experts du groupe intergouvernemental
sur le climat nous ont alertés sur le
fait qu'on avait besoin d'avoir des
mesures fortes le gouvernement dit on
met en place des mesures en l'occurence
n'était pas le cas c'est toujours pas le
cas donc c'est tout simplement pour ça
qu'on a décidé à la fois d'alerté et de
montrer en fait qu'on avait une
nécessité de mettre en place des mesures
fortes
alors par la suite étienne comment ça
s'est passé pour vous sur le plan
judiciaire sur le plan judiciaire donc
six mois après l'action on est allé au
tribunal de paris donc là on a eu une
première une première condamnation dans
lequel on a fait appel et un an après on
était rejugé nouvelle fois ont été
recondamnés est là aujourd'hui on en
cassation pour essayer d'aboutir à une
relaxe donc c'est un peu notre notre
dernière chance entre guillemets on a la
science était du sursis 500 euros
d'amendé ça exactement c'était 500 euros
d'amendé avec sursis pour l'abreuver
instances étaient 500 euros ferme puis
celle des 500 euros avec sursis donc on
a eu un peu moins à la deuxième instance
mais d'autres affaires similaires ont
abouti à des relaxes qu'est ce que ça
signifie pour vous dans l'impression
qu'ils aiment justice un peu à deux
vitesses oui en fait on a eu il ya
évidemment des d'autres procédures dans
lequel il ya eu des relaxes souvent
c'était en première instance est
rarement jusqu'en cassation donc elles
ont toujours aussi abouti à un appel de
la part de l'état pour justement
recondamné ces activistes et donc là
nous ce qu'on attend justement qu'on
arrive en cassation c'est vraiment
d'arriver à aboutir à une véritable
relaxe qu'ils soient donc jugé en
cassation ce qui est la plus haute
juridiction en france quoi quel regard
vous portez sur le décrochage de
portraits aujourd'hui et vous pourriez
leur faire c'est pas notre première
notre première tentative mais
aujourd'hui c'était devenu indispensable
de pouvoir mener une action de
transgresser la loi entre guillemets
pour faire vivre ce message pour
l'exprimer et pour qu'en fait ils
puissent véritablement aboutir à des
actes qu'est ce que vous faites partie
de ces français qui sont en totale
rupture avec emmanuel macron disons que
la rupture avec emmanuel macron s'est
pas particulièrement avec lui en tant
que personne c'est plus aujourd'hui en
fait le gouvernement macron n'est pas à
la hauteur aujourd'hui je dirais pas
qu'il ya un candidat ou une candidate
qui serait à la hauteur en réalité il ya
des mesures qui sont apportées il ya une
franchise à avoir et aujourd'hui elle
est clairement pas du conte et emmanuel
macron ça c'est une certitude on s'est
très clairement en fait si on a le même
mandat macron lors de la prochaine
élection on va aboutir à la même une
action en tout cas là où même mensonge
mm
ou même petite mesure est ce qu'ils
seront pas à la hauteur et on aurait
besoin justement d'avoir il ya beaucoup
de programmes qui sont aujourd'hui plus
ou moins à la hauteur à voir aussi si
ces personnes seront aussi en capacité
de pouvoir les mener est ce qu'elle est
ce que c'est aussi tout simplement
demandé des messages de campagne en tout
cas on attend au tournant qui est
véritablement
des engagements qu'ils soient pris est
qui et qui passe aussi à l'assemblée et
au sénat la voix des français qui se
cherchent parfois et qui pour beaucoup
d'entre eux attendent des mesures fortes
des candidats à la présidentielle alors
emmanuel macron malmené parfois dans les
sondages peut-il reconquérir les
français on attend vos réactions sur le
conte télégramme d'ayrté france et place
à notre face à face
avec nous pour en parler sur ce plateau
julien audy le porte parole du
rassemblement national bonsoir julien on
roule à vos côtés à distance cyrille
isaac sibille député modem du rhône
bonsoir monsieur isaac à six mille merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
donc le gouvernement macro ans qui n'est
pas à la hauteur il ya une franchise à
voir et elle n'est pas dans le camp
macron vois ça voici en substance un
stadier diène coubard qu'on a entendu un
le décrochage de deux portraits vous
comprenez la critique sybille isaac
sibille vous vous ne trouvez pas
spécialement justifier
mon politique j'ai la mémoire
la mémoire c'est qu'est ce qui s'est
passé à cinq ans
souvenez vous il ya cinq ans au shibuya
cinq hommes il ya cinq ans il ya deux
mois enfin au mois au mois deux au mois
d'octobre
2010 est 2016 excusez moi c'était à la
gilles pays qui était qu'un rabbinique
au mois d'octobre
il ne peut pas au mois de novembre il
n'hésitait pas à ce moment tenant fin
novembre c'était françois fillon qui les
rendra duc
souvenez vous aussi à cinq ans le
président sortant françois hollande
était amené à renoncer elle candidats
tellement il était impopulaire
maintenant regardons la situation
actuelle on n'a jamais eu un président
enfin on n'a jamais une politique d'un
coin de république ou aussi soutenu par
les français à la veille d'une élection
présidentielle
donc moi j'entends j'ai bien entendu le
reportage sinon j'entends que le plan de
la cour ne peut pas faire l'unanimité
mais je crois que la confiance dans la
politique humaine et
la confiance spontanée est au dessus de
45 ans en moi c'est ce que je lis dans
les études d'opinion
et donc la campagne présidentielle un
combat de présidentielle bien évidemment
va nous réserver des surprises il ya
cinq ans a réservé elle nous a réservé
beaucoup de surprises nous ce qu'il faut
je pense dans le cadre de la majorité
présidentielle ce qu'il faut c'est qu'on
reste calme on a un bilan qu'on va
défendre et y ait des propositions qu'on
va faire et les français décideront mais
j'en dis bien entendu votre e le
reportage précédent on le souhaite on ne
peut enfermer illimité alors va laisser
répond que j'ai les boules qui
réagissait sur ce plateau qui vous a
laissé parler on va quand même jouer en
double avant de vous laisser répondre
voire un petit peu ce qu'il en est
on va montrer un sondage attention
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle sondages et la bobine et
en 2022 pour bfmtv emmanuel macron 23%
pécresse 20% marine le pen 15% eric
zemmour qui continue un petit peu a
chuté 14% deuxième tour valérie pécresse
52% emmanuel macron 48% alors il faut
être honnête il y avait un deuxième
sondage hier qui montre l inverse avec
emmanuel macron quand même l'emportant
julien ondes ou laisse que votre
interlocuteur c'est isaac sibille a
raison emmanuel macron il n'est pas si
détesté plutôt plébiscité par une partie
en tout cas des français beaucoup plus
que ses prédécesseurs à cette époque
avant la présidentielle
on se rassure comme on peut la réalité
c'est que il ya cinq ans et mener le
maquereau il avait un projet aujourd'hui
l'un bilan et ce bilan force est de
constater qu'il est déplorable il est
déplorable on n'a jamais eu un
quinquennat aussi fracture est aussi
bouleversé où les français ont été
divisés on a eu la crise des gilet jaune
qui a laissé énormément de traces qui
n'a jamais été réglée par le président
de la république les préoccupations des
gilets jaunes sur le pouvoir d'achat sur
comment dirais-je le droit à la parole
par la proportionnelle sur une
invisibilité qui aujourd'hui totalement
ahurissante en france les questions qui
ont été posées n'ont pas été accompagnés
de réponse on a un président de la
république il faut bien dire qu'ils sur
tous les volets volet social volet
économique a échoué sur la scène
internationale notre pays a été
immobilier notamment lors de la crise
des sous marins avec avec l'australie et
puis on voit bien que ce président de la
république finalement a été déconnecté
des français déconnectés de leurs
préoccupations déconnectés de leur
quotidien ils les a méprisé dans le
verbe et dans les politiques je vous
rappelle pas la litanie les petites
phrases qui ne sont rien il ya qu'à
traverser la rue pour trouver un emploi
les gaulois réfractaires etc et puis le
bilan il est clair c'est 6 millions de
chômeurs c'est plus de 10 millions de
pauvres
c'est un français sur trois qui
n'arrivent pas à se soigner pour des
raisons économiques c'est un français
sur cinq aujourd'hui notre pays qui ne
mange pas à sa faim le président de la
république avait dit lors de sa dernière
campagne que plus un seul français ne
dormirait dans la rue on a 4 millions de
français aujourd'hui qu'ils sont mal
logées on a des centaines de milliers de
sdf on a des étudiants qui ne mangent
pas à leur faim qui font la queue aux
restos du coeur c'est ça le bilan de des
mails mâcon et s'il avait la lucidité de
son mentor françois hollande il tirerait
les conséquences de ce bilan et ne se
représenterait pas parce qu'ils sont
bilan est calamiteux je vais vous
laisser répondre série des acteurs
civils ce que je vois que vous réagissez
mais avant je voudrais vous faire passer
une réaction télégramme 1 on a posé la
question aux téléspectateurs aujourd'hui
emmanuel macron alors est-ce qu'il peut
reconquérir les français en tout cas
pour ceux qui ne sont pas déjà conquis
on va regarder pascal 17 ce message
reconquérir encore faudrait-il les avoir
conquis car si ça avait été le cas il
n'y aurait jamais eu besoin dans 92 49 3
il n'y aurait jamais eu de gilet jaune
ni deux manifestations
vous êtes d'accord avec cette analyse
sylvie de isaac sibille c'est vrai que
les gilet jaune ça a quand même marqué
ce quinquennat et entraîné une forme de
rupture avec une partie des français
alors deux choses je sais pas si nous
avançons exact mais on n'a jamais
utilisé 40 2 3 vous décrire sans doute
référence à françois hollande
deuxième chose pour mon contradicteur
dessus ou double est ce qu'on vit
vraiment dans un pays
gg je crois pas
regardez je prends quelques exemples
regardez la crise la crise la gestion
d'âcre il était très critiqué
dans le sens où cela donnerait un fait
qui a fallu faire rêver nos pays voisins
regardez ce qui se passe en allemagne
on est un meilleur élève regardez ce qui
se passe en autriche
regardez ce qui se passe dans tous les
pays de l'est mais ouvrez les yeux je
sais pas si les bijoux vers la france
est un des pays qui a mieux géré la
crise sanitaire
d'autres exemples
entre guillemets vous parler du chômage
le chômage a des tomates à cette façon
il est inférieur à ce qu'il était au
début de la crise on n'a jamais d'aussi
bas rhin chiffre aussi bas du chômage
depuis dix ans l'ensemble de la
catégorie confession llull il y avait en
2003 la croissance on n'a jamais eu une
croissance pour remonter une croissance
pareil il faut remonter à 20 ans
monsieur nous mais ce qu'on vit dans mon
pays la crise sanitaire label du chômage
la croissance entre guillemets on est
actuellement les meilleurs élèves
je sais pas
je ne sais pas si on vit vraiment former
ceux qui souffrent qui ont voulu dire
sutil et peur vous ne développe pas dire
avec les meilleurs élèves c'est un délit
réussi de monsieur c'est indécent parce
que très sincèrement je pense que c'est
vous qui est dans une bulle et c'est
vous qui avaient des oeillères parce que
peut-être qu'à l'assemblée nationale
tout va bien mais allez un peu sur le
terrain il ya des français qui souffrent
qui ont été déclassés et qui ont quêté
que totalement ébréchée par la politique
que vous avez mené depuis cinq ans qui a
été une politique de fracturation
sociale une politique totalement injuste
et ne me parlez pas de la gestion de la
crise sanitaire
excusez moi mais sur la gestion de la
crise sanitaire ça a été lamentable du
début à la fin monsieur v rang qui est
le ministre du mensonge monsieur virant
le ministre du mensonge que ce soit sur
les masques sur les tests sur les
vaccins parce que clairement aujourd'hui
on en est à la caa la troisième voire
quatrième d'eau si on en croit monsieur
delfraissy ce matin donc ça va être
finalement sans fin se passa ni terre
qui est une injustice majeure et qui n'a
aux mesneux sécurité sanitaire donc ça
c'est votre bilan je pense que quand on
si haut si vous aviez la lucidité de
regarder ce bilan en face vous ne seriez
pas là en train de plastronner parce que
clairement les français les français
voient ce bilan et vous disent mais
qu'est ce que vous faites encore à votre
place qu'est ce que vous faites encore à
votre place et j'espère que dans quatre
mois ils vont vous renvoyer à vos études
alors on va vous montrer une autre
réaction télégramme et et jeté une
petite parenthèse un port notre
interlocuteur qui parlait du 49-3 tout à
l'heure ce n'était pas nous inciter un
message cd g emmanuel macron si mes
souvenirs sont bons ils avaient brandi
en tout cas on avait brandi la menace
pour les red
wings n'a pas utilisé parce qu'il ya eu
cette pandémie et finalement la réforme
des retraites et est renvoyé aux
calendes grecques si j'ose dire lors
meloche nous dit mais 9,78 son bilan
n'est pas si mauvais mais si en plus il
baisse la tva pourquoi pas civilisés que
sybille c'est vrai qu'il ya il ya cette
question du pouvoir d'achat qui va être
l'un des thèmes principaux à 2,7 en
panne il est déjà parce qu'il faut pas
oublier de le dire l'inflation de de
retour d'où peut-être aussi la la
campagne que mène emmanuel macron de
rentrer dans les dans les départements
ruraux le pouvoir d'achat oui on non
est-ce qu'il a augmenté sous emmanuel
macron parce que l'insee dit oui mais il
ya si j'ose dire a ressenti des français
comme nous le dira julian donkey et pas
toujours en adéquation avec ces chiffres
officiels tout à fait comme vous le
dites il est chauve actuelle l'initié
dick et oui et je joue plutôt que ans
péan en période de crise c'est plutôt
en série b
on a plutôt bien traversé la crise par
rapport au pointage avait bien
évidemment il faut faire face les
notamment à l'augmentation des des
matières premières de l'énergie
si des causes extérieures la france
auquel tout le monde est confronté ne
dit pas non si si si si ça te fait de
maître qui mondiale le long des tags
monsieur c'est 60% de taxes sur le prix
des carburants donc arretez riscle et
actions venir messieurs vous l'espère de
santé du bar électro les avaient
éliminés c'est une attente pour ce tour
de france et vous n'avez
jamais à aucun moment vous n'avez voulu
baisser les taxes sur les carburants sur
l'électricité sur le gaz qui sont au
plus haut et qui sont même plus haut
qu'au début de la crise et gilet jaune
et pire encore c'est à dire que vous
maintenez une taxe sur une taxe c'est à
dire la tei cpe la tva sur la tpe à
chaque fois que nos compatriotes vont à
la pompe ils paient une taxe sur une
taxe vous n'avez jamais voulu supprimer
cette aberration fiscale qui est une
spécificité française clairement que
nous rassemblons nationale nous avons
demandé notamment par une proposition de
loi de nos députés l'abrogation
voilà donc arrêtez de vous retrancher
derrière les cours de rechange paris
mais monsieur vous ne voulez pas alléger
le viking line au dessus monsieur vous
êtes dans le sentiment moi je suis dans
le fait non je suis à l'arrêt savez la
reine
la réalité c'est quoi c est ce qu ont
augmenté les taxes non est ce que le
prix des matières premières augmentent
et oui est-ce qu'on est d'accord là
dessus est-ce que vous avez baissé les
taxes non voilà non
le fardeau de nos compatriotes c'est un
joueur shirin le meilleur projet qui est
clair c'est rendre 200 euros de pouvoir
d'achat par mois à chaque ménage
français par la baisse des taxes voilà
que ce soit pour les énergies passer de
20% à 5 5 voilà c'est tout ça ce sont
des mesures extrêmement clair voilà vous
ne vous êtes donc finalement le
matraquage ou permanent
ben moi je le vois pratiquement qu'est
ce qu'on a fait et je ne sais pas quelle
somme aucun cas les autres niveaux de
revenu monsieur 12 mai on a baissé la
taxe d'habitation pour la supprimer non
seulement l'abbé simon la supprimer et
ça a grosso modo pour chaque nom mais
c'est pour ça que je demande
effectivement le gâteau savoir qu'une
question de revenus c'est une question
au ciel devrait bientôt ça sert de
localisation de voiliers non seulement
et marine marine le pen propose de
baisser les taxes nous ne la
supprimerons
qui attaquent habitations et je pense
que la suppression de la table itation
sais pas je pensais que je sais c'est un
bain pouvoir à shopall
l'élément on a fait état de mesures ou
entre guillemets on a baissé les impôts
ménages chinois souligne ce qu'ils
disent c'est des chiffres on a supprimé
les taxes sans vous on n'avait pas fait
jeudi j'ai dit par compte et par chaîne
et ils se retrouvent et s'écrit j'avais
raison vous avez passé biasion n'est
plus résister vous avez baissé les
impôts des plus riches donc en passant
de lier sfr wifi ça c'est vrai ça c'est
vrai que pour les plus riches ils ont vu
évidemment que leur feuille d'impôt a
été allégé en revanche pour les classes
moyennes et les classes moyennes
supérieures ça c'est sûr que le fardeau
s'est alourdi considérablement et
aujourd'hui vous avez une paupérisation
des classes moyennes qui ne s'en sortent
plus qui ne s'en sortent plus pourquoi
puisque tout augmente l'électricité le
gaz le les carburants le le panier moyen
tout augmente et vous avez des familles
notamment monoparentales vous avez des
mères célibataires aujourd'hui qui
souffrent et qui n'en peuvent plus fo
face à cela vous ne dites rien et vous
ne faites rien ouais c'est ça qui est
intolérable donc moi je veux bien qu'on
reste sur les statistiques de l'insee
moyenne
je vois dans mon département de l'yonne
avec de plus en plus de pauvres de plus
en plus de précaires avec des français
qui sont assignés à résidence parce
qu'ils ne prennent plus leur voiture ils
ne peuvent plus aller travailler et ils
font le choix au supermarché entre faire
le plein de courses et faire le plein
d'essence voilà la réalité de la france
de monsieur macron izik civile le mot
d'ailleurs pour vous est-ce que vous
avez des incas c'est intéressant parce
que oui la question la question le
monsieur venu chez moi et je le crois
qu'il kim ok propos monsieur 12
rejoindre les propos de monsieur
mélenchon est pour moi là le problème de
la campagne la campagne présidentielle
en ville on verra comment ça se passe
mais pour moi ce n'est pas un problème
de droite ou de gauche il ya des gens
qui veulent plutôt effectivement fermé
les frontières qui veulent se
recroqueviller et des gens qui sont
ouverts d'un côté j'ai des pulsions et
pouvoir d'achat enfin cdi cdd j'en dis
les gars des pessimistes avec des propos
pessimistes comme je viens d'entendre et
puis l'autre côté il ya des gens comme
lui de des propos optimistes avec des
solutions donc d'un côté des gens qui se
ferme ali les propos pessimistes et les
gens qui sont plutôt optimistes avec des
propositions pour continuer à améliorer
la situation du pays et je suis d'accord
avec vous la situation des classes
moyennes qui pour nous est une
préoccupation merci à tous les deux en
tout cas où chacun peut exprimer son
point de vue et c'est l'essentiel c'est
lille isaac sibille merci d'avoir été
avec nos julien houle également et
n'oubliez pas si vous voulez témoigner
dans notre rubrique qu'en pensent les
français je vous rappelle cette adresse
e-mail occupé l'efs at her
tv.fr et un mot de politique pour
terminer un toujours avec une primaire
en réflexion à gauche une gauche qui se
cherche avec arnaud montebourg et anne
hidalgo à la peine dans les sondages la
candidate ps est crédité entre 3 et 7%
le candidat de l'ard montada de la
france entre 1 et 3% pour éviter la
fracture et avoir une chance la
présidentielle est bien la mère de paris
candidate un appel ce soir à la tenue
d'un vote arbitré par les citoyens mais
si cet appel n'est pas entendu anne
hidalgo
retirera pas sa candidature et ira
jusqu'au bout dit-elle écouter
cette gauche fracturée qui aujourd'hui
désespère nos concitoyens doit se
retrouver et se rassembler pour
gouverner le temps est venu de ce
rassemblement nous ne pouvons pas perdre
plus de temps et qu'il ya urgence
urgence à parler de ces sujets qu'on ne
voit plus du tout dans le débat les
services publics la crise écologique
et c'est la fin de cette émission merci
de l'avoir suivi rendez vous demain pour
un nouveau numéro d'ici là n'oubliez pas
de réagir sur notre compte télégramme et
l'actualité continue toute la soirée en
direct sur rt france
[Musique]
chacun prétend détenir la vérité trop
souvent il ne s'agit que de spéculations
[Musique]
il ya ces dérives plus classiques basés
sur l'ésotérisme et il ya un autre
terrain de jeu pour les gourous qu'on a
découvert notamment avec la crise
sanitaire c'est internet on est moins
ceux des jo de mystique moins religieuse
comme on peut et on pouvait la voir dans
les années 70-80 que sur des phénomènes
qui vont concerner la santé ou
l'alimentation et la crise du coc vide à
renforcer cette nouvelle porte d'entrée
dans les dérives sectaires ou des goûts
vous plutôt parler de vaccination plutôt
parler d'alimentation plutôt parler de
guérison au lieu d'aller directement sur
un terrain qui sera un terrain religieux
ou mystique on retrouve par exemple dans
les dernières manifestations anti
vaccins contre locaux vides certains
éléments qui se rattachent à des
mouvements à tendance sectaire qui
historiquement sont opposés à toute
vaccination
vous
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vie des idées
courageuse des mots qui comptent pour la
haine en soi vient des guignols
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extrêmement
saine de la société
[Musique]
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
était formé de gens merveilleux aidé de
jean ignoble en fait vous ne savez pas
comment votre fils est mort vous devez
enquêter sur tout et vous confronter ils
étaient ni sur la liste des morts nés
sur la bbc une surdité hopitalisés il
était nulle part est ce qu'on peut vivre
malgré cette douleur quand j'ai écrit à
la fois je souffrais parce que ça me
rappelait des beaux souvenirs avec
stéphane et en même temps c'était très
douloureux et puis aujourd'hui je me
suis aperçu que ça permettait d'extraire
de moi même toute cette histoire est
donc ça m'a apporté un peu de recul un
peu d'apaisement mais la douleur et la
colère seront là jusqu'à ma mort